23 octobre 1983
ici dans ma tête je suis à bord de votre
mitrailleuses légères dans le bois des
pins mes hommes et moi nous sautons
d'une nuit blanche
nous sommes d'alert au profit des postes
français les postes français à l'époque
on dénombre embarcations on entend alors
que les premières explosions étaient
différentes
deux minutes après une nouvelle
explosion
un peu plus proche le sol tremble un
nouveau jeu sans jeter soit la gravité
de la situation et je me dis là encore
les signes camouflet tu dis à mes
subordonnés mais des moteurs en route
on va certainement demander bouger
effectivement ne pose le commandant le
régiment à la radio le 10 mai gaz et
serrez vous rejoignez les quartiers
ouest
or deux complémentaires vous sont donnés
en cours de route alors que je vais
appeler sur le ring c'est qu'on sorte
d'autoroute intérieur dans beyrouth qui
domine centaine d'immeubles jeu en même
temps de jeu en route le collen l'appel
à la radio rac1
quelques temps plus tard j'apprends que
le tc américain sur l'aéroport a lui
aussi été attaqués et détruits
oui ils sont tout petits
ces 55
et ceux qui sont dans l'éternité son
gant leur courage leur engagement leur
générosité leur sacrifice jeunes n'a pas
abouti c'était la deuxième mission où
vivent petitesse elles sont faits
réalité le pognon qui supplée petit
l'objectif avez vous remarqué le nord
connaître ses tours 5
n'est ce pas peut-être un premier indice
un début de solution
j'aime jouer une première expérience à
laquelle je donnais de vous prêter
rassurez vous c'est pas dangereux sur
votre voisin vous lui mettez alors que
ceux qui mesurent pu la mettre 80 lève
la main les autres étapes change
vraiment petit mais est ce que les
grands sont vraiment si grand que ça et
vous les outils d'une chose de m
ils voulaient petit n'est pas grave si
finalement je vois à se poser ensemble
et pour moi
alors dites moi comment mesure-t-on le
petit et le grand d'un petit 1 c'est la
grandeur quels critères devant une trame
la taille la notoriété le physique la
réputation les résultats des actions
réalisées et diplômes le rang dans la
société le compte en banque le mieux la
vie qu un autre critère agger en fait
nous sommes nous pas tous tout
simplement non
agacé de ce qui est petit il en diffère
sur les hommes la culture la capacité
des finances français alors je vais
défendre l'idée suivante la position de
petite ou de grande et variables dans le
temps car si différemment et concerne
chaque rhône mais ce dans la force
morale et le leadership entraînant les
autres nous appellerons à se sublimer
lors d'événements l inverse peut
malheureusement les précipiter l'homme
sa bassesse à sa décadence chacal reste
cependant livre du chemin qui choisit je
vais maintenant concrétiser
màj vos propos au travers de deux
expériences professionnelles et surtout
humaine qui rêve ma carrière militaire à
l'été 2001 je prends comme colonel le
commandement du 1er 2e régiment de
chasseurs a bien vu sur meuse en vain
c'est une idée imposante par les plus
importants de l'armée de terre ans le
nombre de personnel et le matériel qui
troublent chars leclerc
c'est aussi une très jeune formation
professionnelle le président jacques
chirac ayant décidé à 1996 la pause la
professionnelle de désarmer le régime en
avait lâché ces derniers appelés je
constate de bonnart is certaines lacunes
faiblesses parfois structurels qui
entravent l'unité de taches rebelles et
cette avance la petitesse la
localisation
cybergun est mondialement connu c'est
notre affaire que les militaires que d'y
aller
la mission et le matériel la cavalerie
unique et qui sont plus légères plus
réputés sur la route
le personnel n'a pas d'usiné en actifs
tous les réflexes du professionnel il
est dramatique mais un certain retard
pendant conformité par rapport au modèle
exiger une formation les plus réputés et
jalousé 12les je décide alors que ce
sera la priorité de mes deux années de
commandement faire grandir assure
régiment il n'y a pas d'eau potable il
n'y a que des hommes lâche est capable
l'objectif clairement été levée et de
fer d'environ individuellement et
collectivement mes hommes pour améliorer
les performances du régiment sa
perception et sa crédibilité
je suis attaqué nous sommes couverts
convaincre faire adhérer parfois de
france
si les chasseurs ont globalement répondu
je vais arrêter plus compliqué parfois
avec cadres habitués aux rythmes et aux
styles la conscription pour que le
régime soit grande
il faut que les hommes comme m soit
grand est l'heureux s'est donc joué sur
les moteurs normaux qui supprime l'homme
la fierté le dépassement de soi le
recueil l'intéressement l'image que l'on
donne de soi
le modèle la joie plus concrètement
comment cela s'est il traduit les idéaux
des méthodes spécifiquement militaires
et d'autres qui est simplement en avant
l'argument en chantant le chant de
régime en véritable ciment et identité
de l'unité il ya des peuples alors
modestement j'ai pris le champ de gagner
les gimontois lui le nahd dont les
paroles la mélodie et le titre verdun on
n'est pas certains sont tout simple
poignante et magnifique devises là aussi
c était un véritable rally of le
cohésion de guerre utilisée pour se
motiver
j'ai compté le nombre la nature à la
difficulté d autres écrans et les
compétitions sportives
j'ai créé l'équipe de rugby à la veille
j'ai joué j'ai demandé que l'instruction
un entraînement quotidien sa plus
difficile plus intéressant est réalisée
aussi de nuit j'ai fait modifier la
relation saute d'un cadre la ronde en
plus humaine plus responsable que
conforme entre professionnels je fais à
porter d'embellissement dans le quartier
j'ai fait sortir des soldats du quartier
et je les ai montré à la population tout
simplement un ensemble petites mesures
répéter quotidiennement alors tout cela
pour quoi
les résultats sont fait sentir dès lundi
avec deux commandements style de
commandement comportement résultat
opérationnel est individuelle sportifs
collectifs sur la population le
recrutement la fidélisation et le
bien-être le régime en devenait enfin
grands
c'est en 1992 que l'idée d'une force qui
serait encore
la première guerre du golfe cas de ce
terminal
toujours cette alliance est vraiment
différente de la première
nous voilà j'ai droit l'élite
un peu plus de 3000 hommes les hommes
sélectionnés et choisit soit entraînée
sur l'équité sans vous tirez sur deux
n'est pas d'espoir
il ya des commandos bien sûr il ya les
médecins et des pilotes deux mécaniciens
il ya tout un tas de métiers la
motivation n'est pas un souci
au contraire il faut parfois réfréner
leurs ardeurs
alors me direz-vous quelquefois même pas
le petit essai chez eux
eh oui que ces personnels elle se situe
à la nature et le type r engagement plus
large
c'est un pari gagné bataille par contre
ils prennent à part compte tenu du
risque extrême qui est pris par shark
commando à 16 fr ont installé des forces
spéciales font craindre un instant de
vitesse
le succès n'est pas garanti à chaque
fois c'est bon quoi on parle également
de faibles fois alors ça on tout cela au
travers de quelques exemples l'équipe de
recherche est chargée d'observer leur
enseigner ces cinq à six hommes
positionné en terrain hostile
complètement autonome aucune liaison
avec l'arrière sauf des liaisons année
un groupe action yvonne sommes capables
d'aller libérer les otages de
neutraliser petits ou de défrayer un
adjectif 2006
reiser jacques chirac décide d'emploi de
faire plaisir aux américains c'est vrai
que la carie golfe ne vais pas vous
vient d'être appelé un miracle il décide
de s'engager auprès des américains pour
charge de capturer ben laden et de
trahison kahina il confie cette mission
au fonds spécial
nous déployons à l'aise d'afghanistan
pendant un peu plus de trois ans de 2006
à 2009
les montagnes son hôte et le quine à
vous en parle mais pas les gars 2 et 50
degrés divers le poteau tente la
population et austin adversaires et
aguerris nombreux il nous attend et il
connaît les techniques de guérilla tué
l'un d'entre vous les adorent vie est
grand a pris un bien petit et 2007
quelque part en afrique là où les armes
sont grands là où la forêt est
luxuriante prendre une frontière pays
n'est pas très ami avec la france
quelques centaines de rebelles décident
de rentrer avec un petit détachement
français qu'il faudra gérer avec des
expatriés qui était une fin et quelques
locaux
il est décidé d'intervenir un problème
c'est que
baptiste c'est compliqué dans ce pays il
faut y aller
plusieurs de plusieurs journées pour y
aller donc il est décidé de monter un
show aérien 40 super opérationnels sont
désignés devront dans sa nature
on s'arrête quelque part dans un pays où
là on est des fortins positionner en
afrique offert le plein et puis prendre
la météo parce que pour les shooteurs la
météo c'est important parce que vivant
on prend la météo est à pau en fait le
vent a tourné en dollar gagne le dakar
est un petit peu à côté
en fait c'est son objectif 40 commandos
40 kg quelques centaines de rebelles
car si ça prend un petit s alors de
cette petitesse voit les comprimés la
grandeur
c'est ici que je devais l'autre celle de
l'esprit d'équipé mais aussi d'une
odieuse mans une forme d'autonomie
individuelle la capacité d'adaptation la
force morale le refus de l'échec
l'opportunisme la technicité dans
l'habitat tease à maîtriser moyenne
communication et de renseignement
j'espère que tout comme victor hugo vous
serez éblouis dans la grandeur des
petits l'homme ne vient-il pas grand
finalement race qui fait de grandes
choses
sans avoir la prétention de devenir
grand
je souhaiterais à l'extérieur je vais
vous citer des noms d'hommes et de
femmes ainsi de reading qui selon
rousseau clôture regagner du temps vous
garderez à l'époque par vous même vous
pourrez la partager au monde un peu hâlé
louis de funès me l'a dit l'abbé pierre
à facebook gengis khan
l'epic bay mike tyson le soldat inconnu
mozart la gym colle pour les hommes
adriana 40 en fait nous sommes tous
petits et grands
plus ou moins petitesse landes honneur
qu existe chez l'homme de manière
inévitable et illégale la générosité
n'est d'évidence le dépassement de soi
le fond de mir ror inverse
l'égoïsme fanatisme la facilité le rôle
de petit l'actualité quotidienne ne vous
rappelle-t-il pas je laisserais
cependant le dernier mois montaigne un
qui nous rassure enfin sur cette
question existentielle la petitesse de
la grandeur saut de plus au trot hop
rock du monde on n'est jamais assis
hélas le cse de choisir après avoir été
commis et non la première depuis bien
vrai que vous plaisir